Se trata de hacer las preguntas correctas.
Pero puede crear numerosas oportunidades para evaluar hipótesis biológicas.
Si nuestras predicciones coinciden con nuestras observaciones,
¡excelente!, acertamos y ya podemos hacer otras predicciones,
cambiando tal o cual aspecto del modelo.
Pero si nuestras predicciones no coinciden con nuestras observaciones,
significa que son incorrectas algunas de nuestras suposiciones
y que nuestro entendimiento de los mecanismos clave
de la biología básica
es aún incompleto.
Por suerte, como este es un modelo,
controlamos todos los supuestos.
Y podemos analizarlos uno a uno
e identificar cuál o cuáles ocasionan la discrepancia.
Y luego podemos llenar este nuevo vacío de conocimiento
mediante el uso de métodos experimentales y teóricos.
Claro está que cualquier ecosistema es sumamente complejo,
e intentar describir todas las piezas en movimiento no solo es difícil
sino también muy poco informativo.
También está el tema de las escalas temporales,
porque algunos procesos ocurren en una escala de segundos, o minutos,
o días, meses o años.
Puede que no siempre sea posible separarlas experimentalmente.
Y algunas cosas pasan a un ritmo tan lento o tan veloz
que quizá nunca se las llegue a medir físicamente.
Pero como matemáticos,
tenemos el poder de focalizarnos en cualquier subsistema,
en cualquier escala temporal,
y simular los efectos de las intervenciones
que ocurren en cualquier escala temporal.
Es obvio que esta tarea no es solo del modelador.
Debe haber una estrecha colaboración con los biólogos.
Y sin dudas requiere de cierta capacidad para traducir
de ambas partes.
Pero comenzar con una formulación teórica de un problema
puede crear numerosas oportunidades para evaluar hipótesis
y simular escenarios e intervenciones terapéuticas
de una manera absolutamente segura.
Puede identificar vacíos de conocimiento y contradicciones lógicas
y nos puede guiar por el camino correcto
e indicarnos los posibles callejones sin salida.
En otras palabras,
los modelos matemáticos pueden ayudar a responder preguntas
que afectan de forma directa a la salud de la gente;
en realidad, la salud de cada uno de nosotros...
porque la modelación matemática será clave
para impulsar la medicina personalizada.
Todo se reduce a hacer la pregunta correcta
y traducirla a la ecuación correcta,
y viceversa.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)